sauver ou périr c'est le titre du
dernier film de frédéric tellier
j'aimais l'idée que ce métier puisse me
rendre fort et et c'est que personne
n'étant ainsi les pompiers ne sont pas
invincibles
face aux flammes malgré leur équipement
qui n'a cessé d'évoluer au fil des ans
pour toujours plus de sécurité se dont
la devise est sauver ou périr ont bien
mérité d'être à l'honneur dès les années
l'équipement était sophistiqué avec les
premières combinaisons ignifugées 12 200
degrés dans ce joli feu de bois
mais dans son vêtement à l'épreuve du
feu
c'est à peine si l'expérimentateur sent
une légère sueur humecter son front les
équipements se renouvelle sans cesse
les innovations sont présentés tous les
ans au congrès national sapeurs pompiers
qui existe depuis 1882 cette bouteille
d'air peut sauver beaucoup de vies
c'est la trouvaille de l'année elle
double l'autonomie des pompiers qui
s'engouffre dans les 110 pour secourir
les victimes
des bouteilles d'air dont les premiers
modèles sont arrivés dans les années 60
pour lutter contre leur vieil ennemi le
feu de sous sol ils ont ajouté à leur
panoplie le masque anti fumée et
l'appareil respiratoire individuelle
mais que serait l'homme du feu sans son
fameux casque un casque est une
invention française dont les géologues
aouita ziem vanter les mérites en 1985
ou mais très solide exceptionnel vous
allez voir ailleurs qu il me vint cerf
bien malgré ses innovations
les pompiers ne sont pas à l'abri du
danger et des flammes
les conséquences peuvent être terribles
comme le soulignait ce grand brûlé en
2004 j'ai refusé réellement de voir mon
visage d'en prendre réellement
conscience avant d'avoir les premières
opérations de chirurgie reconstructrice
sont mon visage
[Musique]